- Checking out a bird mount, or a skull,
or a fish mount is just
like checking out a book.
You present your library
card, we scan it, it's due
in two weeks, and it's just
like checking out a book.
This is the Alaska resources
library and information
services, and we're in the
room that holds the furs,
mounts and skulls in our collection.
Many of the items are
available for the public.
- The focus of the collection
is Alaskan animals,
birds, and fish.
I'd says there are hundreds of furs.
Probably 50 bird mounts,
and hundreds of skulls.
- This has a walrus skull,
which is kind of interesting.
It's got teeth behind the tusks.
I didn't realize that until
I got to look at the skull,
it was pretty cool.
(playful music)
- The bear furs are really popular,
well, bear, lynx, and wolf.
When people encounter this
collection, they are delighted.
They ooh and ah.
It sparks their imagination,
they love having all the choice
of the different types
of items that we have.
People who check out
these items really vary,
mainly teachers, for their
Alaska animal component
of their curriculum.
- I don't know of anywhere
else that they can borrow
a mounted sandhill crane
and just study it up close.
It's a very unusual program.